اضافه الى بريطانيا فان اسرائيل لا يحكمها
جسورا مكتوب بل تحكمها مجموعه قوانين
تتغير بتغير الحكومات والمصالح اسرائيل
تشهد حاليا احتجاجات في شوارعها هي الاكبر
والاوسع منذ عام 48 دوائر الاضراب فيها
تسعت لتطال الموانئ والمطارات والسبب
انقسام داخلي حول تعديل قضائي من شانه ان
يحد من صلاحيات محكمه العدل العليا لصالح
رئيس الحكومه فصلاحيات السلطات القضائيه
ليست ثابته ولا محدده بنصوص دستوريه وفي
الوضع الحالي يرى المؤيدون للتعديل انا
للقضاه سلطه نافذه اكبر من الحكومه
المنتخبه وان الحكومه احق بتلك الصلاحيات
اما المعارضون سيرون في التعديل مهربا
لمازق الرئيس الحكومه اليمينيه المتطرفه
بنيامين نتنياهو من تهم الفساد التي
يواجهها وبالنسبه للمحتاجين في الشارع فقد
ارتفع س قف مطالبهم ليصل حد المطالبه بوضع
دستور ثابت غير قابل للتغيير لكن لماذا لم
تحدد اسرائيل دستورها منذ البدايه محللون
يرجعون السبب الى عدم قدره مكونات المجتمع
الاسرائيلي المختلفه والمتباينه على
الاتفاق وتحديد هويه الدوله وعلودها
ورؤيتها وعلاقه الدين في صنع القرار فيها
اضافه الى كل التعاملات المتغيره مع حقوق
الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]